a million questions
um uh obviously you're a part of Andor
but what has it actually been like for
you watching the show because it is so
effing incredible that I'm sure as a fan
you're enjoying it as much as as all of
us are quite right I mean look I was a
huge fan of Rogue one and that was that
was what what made me want to come back
into the universe
it was going to cause a huge amount of
kind of speculation and and going
through the whole of this and everything
again and opening and you know I just
didn't want to be part of you know
making people's lives more complicated
than they they already are you're going
to work out what I was doing coming back
into you know but but as soon as I
talked to Tony Tony Gilroy and you know
as I say I was such a big fan of Rogue
one and and we talked about the part and
and just I I love the the world that he
creates the out the every man kind of uh
aspect of of the film The the film of
Rogue one and then and then and then as
you say the the gray areas the
complexities of all of the characters
that go into this amazing amazing
Odyssey um and of not least of course
working with Diego and uh you know who's
just phenomenal but it's such a great
cast of actors and and every single
character better rich beautifully drawn
extraordinarily kind of complex and and
uh yeah just it was it was it was just a
treat to to come back into it uh what is
the secret to not blinking
uh why do I not blink I'm I I watch your
performance specifically uh I watched
the episodes again yesterday and I'm
like it's amazing how little you blink
when it's a close-up on you God that's
interesting because Michael Caine
famously said in his master class you
know whatever happens don't blink you
know
have you seen that I've heard all about
it and it's true though when you're
watching an actor not blink you're being
pulled in and uh it's just anyway but
you you do it very well I'm just curious
what's the secret
uh I don't I wasn't even aware that I
was doing that I think it's I think it's
just like the intensity of the character
and the kind of the mindset that he's in
um it just sort of
you do these things that sometimes you
know you can intellectualize about the
character and the formation of the
character but but sometimes what
actually happens to your your facial
expression or your or the way that
you're you know I wasn't conscious it
was probably the it was probably the
it was more kind of the thought process
than than actually thinking right I'm
gonna not I'm not gonna blink you know I
I you know it's it's really it was about
I suppose he he is an intense character
and I think there's a sort of
um
a natural Authority that he has and and
I I created this backstory for King
noloy which was was that he was this it
was like a kind of a shop steward in a
form of life and and he has a family and
and and yet and and he would have fought
for workers rights on the outside you
know before he was incarcerated but he
would have been seen as a troublemaker
for that so when he when he was
incarcerated he uh he then kind of
almost sheds any desire to to look out
for other people apart from himself just
do his time and get out try and get out
and just survive the sentence the
torture the the the uh you know the the
desensitization and I think it's that
desensitization that made me perhaps
have that sort of slightly kind of lost
but kind of
hardened and toughened shell maybe maybe
that's where that intensity comes from
uh what has it been like for you uh to
have these two awesome roles in the
Batman and Andor that showcase your
acting without special effects or
emotion capture or any of that stuff
it's just you your performance well you
know Steve I mean I think we've had the
conversation before but it you know and
and but it is worth saying I
whatever character I play it's about the
process of of building that character
and then the manifestation of it
really for me I don't particularly say
for instance like watching myself on on
camera
as myself or or more than you know more
than watching myself transform into a
digital character it's it's it's it's
how powerful the performance is and if
it works then great not the
manifestation and so
so I don't really feel anything you know
I I you know if if it's moving as a as a
CG Incarnation then I feel I've done my
job and if it's it's moving and touching
or powerful or whatever you know it's in
as myself then then
equally it then then equally it's it you
know I feel like I've done the job and
that's and that's that's all that's all
that you do as an actor it's it's
creating a role that hopefully touches
people in some way so so yeah I don't I
don't feel different or anything you
know watching my you know watching
Alfred or or King oloy versus Caesar or
you know it's I mean yes I I it's
you know you're you're exposed in
different ways I guess just randomly
while I'm sitting across from you I
realized I wanted to ask you this
um I loved rings of power on Prime video
uh which is you know Lord of the Rings
um and I'm just curious if you got to
watch any of it and what your thoughts
were yeah I I I've absolutely watched it
and uh you know it really once you know
you get through the
uh understanding the rules of it of it
and and and and actually how loyal to
the trilogy and the the feel of the
trilogy
um music by Howard Shore for the opening
sequence Etc you know it's it's um
it actually I found it incredibly
engaging and I I really really enjoyed
watching it and and also
um I I because I'd done an audio book
recording of of The Lord of the Rings
and read the appendices and had to read
them out loud I sort of was quite clued
up about about that particular you know
where it was going to go which was which
was which was great and it was really
helpful because I'm going to be don't
tell anybody but reading this
silmarillion as well so
um
uh you heard this here first
um so yeah no so I really enjoyed it
very much so uh first of all thanks for
sharing and second of all for anyone who
has not watched uh rings of power we're
talking about Endor but rings of power
is also pretty good I so I am curious
though what was it like for you because
I'm I'm Blown Away by every aspect of
Andor in terms of the production design
the costumes cinematography the script
you name it I'm just really blown away
but what was it like stepping on set and
seeing the sense they had built for the
prison cells and for where the machine
shop if you will it was extraordinary
and very daunting and you know that and
also
it really gave you look the we were
walking on metal plates for weeks with
bare feet and that sapped your energy
and really and also the the costume
design you know the prison outfits are
so you know they're formed in such a way
that take away any sense of your own
identity so everything that that was
done to create that world really worked
on you psychologically
um and you know that like you say the
machine parts
um the the process of creating the the
the the bit the the pieces that that are
being put together by the whole team
that had to be thoroughly worked out you
know the the the the the you know the
actual design worked really well with
the choreography of what had to be done
to create those paths
um and so everything about it and the
cells there was no sense of
kind of individuality about everything
and that really really plays on with
your mind and with your head when you're
working on a set like that day in day
out so it had the desired effect for
sure but it was mind-blowing I mean the
main shop floor was was just incredible
um and then equally the the long those
long tubes that kind of exit and entry
Gates where they they go past every day
you know it really was
um you know being trapped it was like
being trapped in these enormous test
tubes for days
um and so that did that was kind of real
you know it really again sort of wore
you wore you down a bit actually
um you know there's no private space no
sense of just as an actor you know you
normally find your little set you know a
little bit on the set somewhere where
you can go and sit in between tags or
whatever you know you had to stand
because there wasn't enough room or you
had to or you you know it was it was
sort of like you really did feel like
you were incarcerated in some strange
weird place did you guys is on set ever
debate or did Tony ever tell you what
these pieces that everyone was building
actually were going were or was it sort
of like it's really unimportant what
they're building
it's really important what they're
building and I think for the for those
who who have a Keen Eye and uh you know
and who know the law of Star Wars will
find that the pieces that that are being
made are I'm not going to give it away
because they'll have to
dig around for yourself but I'm sure
there are theories about what those
parts are sure sort of circulating on it
perhaps but I like having that person
who is on the show uh to talk about it
but anyway but I'm not going to give it
away